hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer questions
from one of my readers Molly who wrote
to me at 4:00 in the morning she decided
she wanted to change your life and stop
being a dream wisher and actually go out
and create her own future and one of my
advice on how to do it she said she
enjoys helping people and wanted to be a
speaker on stage delivering a key
message that was you know really
providing value for people but wasn't
quite sure how to go about at one of my
advice and what to do so Molly Congrats
on making that change in your life
hopefully my you know what you can do is
is something every day to keep that
momentum going
often people you know get that energy at
the beginning to start a business and
then it quickly fizzles out as you know
you let life get back in the way so keep
trying to do something every day to help
you grow that business so congrats on
taking that initial first step and
writing in as well for advice and terms
of being a speaker and being on stage
and helping people and delivering your
message and having people kind of
interact with that the first thing to
figure out is what is your message so
you didn't kind of include that in your
email and you might still be figuring
that out and that's fine
figure out what it is that you want to
say so what's uniquely you where do you
think you can help people and think back
to where you you have been able to give
a lot of help to people and give a lot
of value and make people think about
what you're saying and now can you
tailor that to be your message that you
deliver to a bigger audience so step one
is figuring what that message is and
make sure it's something that you can
quickly deliver even in one sentence so
that people can quickly grasp what it is
that you do so oh that's Molly and she
talks about XYZ and she's fantastic
so figure out your messages is number
one from there in terms of being able to
be a speaker and be on stage and get
paid to do what you're doing you got to
start at the beginning
so you start small you start doing you
know small events it could be at the
library or local charities or local
events and you know you might not get
paid at the beginning to do it you just
practicing your craft
what that will do is is help hone your
message and also make you more
comfortable out there speaking in front
of people and getting used to the types
of questions that will come at you and
they'll make your presentation better
and better and better and better and
better when I first started doing public
speaking it wasn't with a goal to be a
public speaker it was more just to help
entrepreneurs so it sold my business and
I stopped you know I want to give back
and want to help other entrepreneurs and
I created a series to help entrepreneurs
learn from the lessons that I had gone
through and I just did it you know
through my local YMCA at the beginning
and I think the first first time I did
had three or four people in it so really
tiny and then it you know we just
continue doing it and continue growing
in the built up momentum behind that and
eventually partnered up with a bank and
hosted it their event and then group you
know too big for that so we partnered up
with our bookstores and whole you know
held huge events we had lots of people
coming out to the seminars and it was a
lot of fun for me be able to give back
you offer value to entrepreneurs and it
also made me better you know my first
presentations the content was good but
how I delivered it wasn't great you know
he got it gets better every time you
practice just like doing these videos I
get better and better every time we do
the videos if you go back and watch the
first videos the content was still
pretty good but maybe the delivery
wasn't fantastic so as you do more and
more you get better so people start to
recognize you people start to give you
referrals people start to say oh you
should be speaking up here or I want you
to come speak up my company or whatever
it is so you have to be able to practice
practice practice and eventually you'll
get better and people will recognize you
the other thing I would do is try to
become a media expert so whatever your
message is there are going to be stores
written about it in the media and the
media are always looking for experts to
comment on whatever that story is and
why shouldn't you be that expert so you
want to make a list of reporters who
follow your industry or who write about
interesting stories for you and whenever
they do write an article comment on it
give them feedback and let them know who
you are and give you a perspective it's
not just being promotional and saying
you know I'm Molly and here's what I do
you want to give them something extra
you want to show that you are really an
expert so that they're gonna want to
contact you if they have another story I
also use a service called PR leads which
is 100 bucks a month where reporters
will give you stories so they'll tell
you the service are working on and
they're looking for experts so you can
just email them and say no here's a I'm
an expert and here's why and you give
them feedback on it on their story that
they're working on so I find that
helpful so start speaking try to be a
media expert the last thing I would do
is if you're trying to get a public
speaking gig try working on your YouTube
videos as well I don't know if you've
done YouTube at all but it's a great way
to get your message out and if you're a
speaker you should try to speak as much
as you can now you know when you're
doing a YouTube video you're speaking to
the camera instead of speaking to an
audience we just kind of have to pretend
that there's a huge audience in front of
you and not just you in a room speaking
but it's a great way to get your message
out for you to also practice your crap
and for people to see how good you are
so most of my speaking now is from you
two questions just like this one the
question you ask but I'll also do others
from you know profiles of successful
entrepreneurs in lessons you can learn
for you you might not have people asking
you questions yet but you can just go to
forums that are related to your topic
and see what people are writing about
and say that you're gonna create a video
reply and when you you know create your
video say I'm creating this video in
response to whoever who asks a question
about XYZ that relates to your topic so
I try to get consistent on you know
creating these videos building up a
following getting people to see you and
it makes you better homes your message
even more and you'll get gigs so you
know from what I was doing just just
from those public speaking things that
I'd set up here in my city I then got
invited eventually to go speak at
various events around the world or
flying to - as far away as Brunei Taiwan
to speak at different events and it
comes from starting at that you know
small scale - beginning now I never had
that vision - wanna go on be a speaker
just kind of happened but for you if you
have a clear plan
you know you got to practice as much as
you can get as many games as you can
free just to get your message home and
to get people to know you and continue
building on that don't try to be a media
expert and try to create some YouTube
videos again to practice your craft and
be seen as the expert and you're on your
way to be able to be a speaker to
hopefully get paid and have a really
fulfilling career so while I hope that
helps for those watching if you guys
have something else to add please leave
a comment below I'd love to hear how
you've gotten some speaking gigs or if
you have another question or any
suggestions from Molly please leave a
comment and if you liked the video
please give it a thumbs up I love making
these videos to help you guys out and
always appreciate those thumbs ups
coming in makes me know that you guys
like the videos and keep making more so
thank you for your support and we'll see
you on the next episode
you